dust Falls in a Mexican Cemetery
but these white suited figures are here
to give some of its denizens a second
chance at life
a swarm of bees who've made this grave
their home the latest rescue effort for
the black bee a company who've relocated
more than 500 hives in Mexico City in
the last six years
the most common places to find them are
lamp posts between walls on roofs trees
in abandoned car tires those are the top
five places I'd say
foreign
bees are seen as a stinging problem
Emergency Services often destroy hives
and there are other threats across the
country and elsewhere too use of
damaging chemicals the loss of their
natural habitats even climate change it
means B numbers are nose diving
worldwide and that's a big problem not
just for them but also us says Adriana
the black bee founder
seven everyday foodstuffs that we
consumer pollinated by bees so they're
really important but it's bigger than
that thirty percent of what cattle eat
is pollinated by them the wood you use
in Furniture is in part pollinated by
bees everything has to do with them
the group douses bees with smoke and
water droplets to keep them calm then
it's time to take them out and put them
in their Temporary Home
Adriana and her team estimate that
there's about 90 000 bees in this Hive
but they say that the most important to
rescue are the larvae and the eggs
because it's those that will mean that
the bees are able to populate their new
home quicker
that new home is here in the hives that
the group maintain in their base
this is the rehabilitation part not all
of the bees that come here are in good
health sometimes the Emergency Services
spray them with chemicals so here
they're in quarantine they stay a while
get strong then go into donation or if
they've got really good genetics we keep
them here as nurses for the next hives
a bee at a time a swarm every rescue
working to help ensure the future of a
species that's important to the whole
ecological system
John Holman Al Jazeera Mexico City